hello my name is inigo montoya you
killed my father prepare to die that's
not really my name I'm Rob Reiner and I
want to welcome you to this wonderful
25th anniversary screening of The
Princess Bride I'm so happy you're all
here i want to say first of all it's
inconceivable that it's 25 years since
we first showed this movie i'm so happy
that it's lasted this long and i want to
tell you i get such a thrill when people
come up to me and quote line from the
movie they say to me as you wish or
inconceivable or have fun summer they
say these wonderful lines and what's
really thrilling is that 25 years ago
kids who were eight nine ten years old
are now adults and they have kids and
they're showing the kids there the film
and they're enjoying it again over so i
love that it's standing the test of time
i have one story to tell you before you
enjoy the film years ago i went to a
restaurant and i'm sitting at this
restaurant of the italian restaurant new
york city and in walks John Gotti and
he's got six wise guys with him and I'm
looking over there and I kind of noticed
him and he kind of noticed me I didn't
want to notice me too much and we're
having dinner finished dinner I walk
outside and they're standing in front of
this limousine is a guy that looks like
Luca Brasi from the Godfather and he
stares me in the face and he says you
killed my father prepare to die and I
thought I almost went to the bathroom
right there on the sidewalk and he says
I love that movie The Princess Bride
it's a great movie so when we when we
when we make it to where the Mafia is
enjoying the movie we know that we have
a success so I want to say enjoy the
movie I got two things to say before we
thought the movie one is as you wish and
have fun storming the castle have a good
time